رجب طيب اردوغان وحزبه امام امتحان جديد
واقوى تحد منذ عشرين عام على راس السلطه
البلاد على اعتاب انتخابات رئاسيه
وبرلمانيه غير مسبوقه الانتخابات تاتي في
ظل تزايد الشكاوى بشان عداله ونزاهه عمليه
التصويت المعارضه تقول ان الانتخابات
لطالما جرت على ارضيه غير متكافئه مزاعم
غالبا ما يدعمها المراقبون الدوليون ابرز
الامثله التي تطرحها المعارضه التركيه
التغطيه الاعلاميه التي يتمتع بها اردوغان
واستخدام موارد الدوله اثناء الحملات
الانتخابيه والتفسير المشكوك فيه لقانون
الانتخابات فحوالي 90% من وسائل الاعلام
التركيه تتركز في ايدي الحكومه وداعمها
وفق منظمه مراسلون بلا حدود ما يضمن وقتا
اطول من البث لصالح الرئيس فخلال شهر
ابريل الماضي حصل اردوغان على ما يقرب من
33 من البث على محطه التلفزيون التركيه
الرسميه في المقابل حصل خصمه الرئاسي كمال
كلتش دار اوغلو على 32 دقيقه فقط حزب
الشعب الجمهوري المعارض الابرز رفع دعوى
قضائيه الشهر الماضي ضد محطه تي ار تي
الرسميه لفشلها في عرض فيديو حملته
من جهته اكد حزب العداله والتنميه بقياده
اردوغان انه ملتزم باجراء انتخابات حره
ونزيهه تحترم اراده الشعب اردوغان ينوه
بدمقراطيه التجربه التركيه اذ يسعى
للاحتفاظ بالسلطه ومواصله قياده البلاد
رغم الانتقادات اللاذعه التي يواجهها في
ظل ازمه اقتصاديه غير مسبوقه فضلا عن اثار
الزلزال الاخير بلال البجدين العربيه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات